[Music]
here are a couple of general rules which
may not apply all the time but do seem
to apply in this case the first is that
bipartisan legislation is the worst kind
of legislation if there's any idea any
proposal
that can bring both republicans and
democrats together and put them on the
same page with each other
you know it must be uniquely terrible
the second rule is that when it comes to
long-standing personal disputes between
people especially people who are close
to each other especially family members
if you know only one side of the story
then you don't know the story your
opinion on the subject will be therefore
basically worthless now with that
groundwork laid let's
begin with republican representative
nancy mace who along with democrat
charlie crist
and their bipartisan gang of legislators
are pushing a bill which they have
dubbed the
free brittany act this obviously stems
from the outcry over the conservatorship
of britney spears who was denied the
right to make legal decisions for
herself
after the court determined that she's
not mentally fit to do so
this decision was made over a decade ago
i think like 13 or 14 years ago
following a very public mental breakdown
actually a series of mental breakdowns
by
britney spears and for the past many
years that decision has been repeatedly
affirmed by the courts
the courts have said that britney spears
is mentally unfit
and potentially a danger to herself or
others but britney's fans and now the
public at large after seeing a new york
times documentary on the subject
have decided that the courts got it
wrong they have declared that britney
spears should be freed from her
conservatorship
which had granted a decision making
powers to her father instead of herself
um brittany herself now is also calling
for the arrangement to be terminated
and now our lawmakers never letting
ill-informed hysteria go to waste
have jumped into the fray many
republicans have still not said a word
in defense of the january 6th rioters
who've been
locked in prison for months on
trespassing charges
even as blm militants who burned
buildings and assaulted police officers
go free
and yet those republicans still have
time to worry about britney spears
to that end here is nancy mace making
her case on fox news here it is
thank you arthel for having me on this
afternoon the free act
well first of all i want to thank
britney spears it took a lot of courage
for her to come forward in a very public
way as a celebrity and public figure
detailing the abuses of her
conservatorship
just last month in june and her
situation is a total nightmare and if it
can happen to her of all people then it
can happen to anyone
and what this piece of legislation would
do would allow someone like brittany
who's in a conservatorship
to petition a judge petition the court
for an independent or public guardian
someone that could oversee the
conservatorship who doesn't have a
conflict of interest
financial or otherwise that's really at
the crux of this and there are 1.3
million people in conservatorships
across the country today okay
so there are two basic questions to be
dealt with here one is whether this
legislation is needed or warranted
and the other more broadly is whether
britney's fans and instagram followers
and people who saw new york times
documentary are correct in their legal
assessment of the case and their
psychological assessment of britney
spears so we'll look into both of these
questions beginning with the first
do we need this legislation well mace
and lots of people in the free brittany
movement have echoed this claim as well
may says that this is a larger problem
she says that conservatorship abuse is a
widespread issue in this country we got
to do something about it
but she also says that 1.3 million
people are under conservatorships
well in a country of some 330 million
people that means if my math is right
and it usually isn't
that what point three percent of all
americans are under conservatorships
not knowing anything about any of those
cases point three percent seems like a
rather
reasonable figure at first glance is it
possible that point three percent of
americans are mentally unfit to make
decisions for themselves
uh yeah clearly so if anything it seems
that the number should be significantly
higher than it is
i'm a little bit upset that it's not
larger than that
a better question is is it true that
that only point three percent of
americans are unfit to make decisions
for themselves only point three percent
now may says that if it can happen to
britney it can happen to anyone
but it doesn't happen to anyone it
doesn't happen to hardly anyone
it's happened to only 0.3 percent of the
country what do you mean it could happen
to anyone
yeah but is it
no i'm not arguing that there's no need
for
conservatorship reform what i'm arguing
is that the facts about britney spears's
case
what little we know and the fact that
1.3 million people are subject to these
arrangements
don't themselves add up to a need for
sweeping reform
if a better case can be made then mace
should make it
if there is some real far-reaching
serious problem with the way
conservatorships are handled in this
country
then present the facts and make your
argument but then if that far-reaching
serious problem exists
why did you wait for britney spears
to bring this up why are you basing this
on the britney spears case
why do you bring this up before see
there are a lot of people who are today
pretending to be experts on
conservatorships oh you know this is a
major problem in this country
yeah it's a big problem well yeah but
you never mentioned a word about that
until britney spears was in the news
why is that if it's a big problem where
was your conservatorship reform movement
before this
as for the spears case specifically
is it true that she's being oppressed
and abused by her conservatorship is it
true that the courts ought to
free her before we can answer that if we
can answer it
we should establish one thing it is
certainly possible in principle for an
adult to exhibit behavior which would
lead to them losing the right to make
decisions for themselves
severely mentally ill people exist
dangerous and suicidal people exist
that's why we have mental institutions
that's why we have conservatorships the
way some people are talking about this
case it's as though they object
in principle to the very idea that any
adult should be deprived of the right to
make decisions
like the way that they say oh she's an
adult she should make decisions well yes
but
what if she's crazy are you saying that
no one should have their
decision-making power taken from them at
all
well if that's your argument then you're
arguing for the abolition of all mental
asylums and psychiatric hospitals
you're arguing that any person no matter
how disturbed
no matter how erratic or
self-destructive should be permitted to
continue making choices for themselves
even if those choices are almost
guaranteed to lead to them harming
themselves or other people
or their own children now you're free to
make that argument but it's an absurd
and
stupid argument and not one that any
intelligent person should take seriously
rational people can see that dangerously
irrational people exists and sometimes
on rare occasion remember we're only
talking about 0.3
here steps must be taken to bring them
under control for their own safety and
the safety of others
if we've established that if we can
agree that conservatorships exist for a
reason and should continue to exist
and the only question is whether britney
spears should be under one or not
in order to say no to that question we
would need to have evidence
compelling evidence that she is mentally
competent
do we in the public have that evidence
no
what do we have we have her instagram
page
where just this weekend she posted
topless pictures now that's not illegal
i'm not saying anyone who posts a topic
topless picture should have their
decision-making rights taken away from
them
but is it a normal and rational thing to
do when you're in the middle of a legal
battle
over your conservatorship you're posting
naked pictures online
is that something that a normal healthy
minded person does
but we have that um we have a
documentary produced by the new york
times in which spears
spears fans and spears advocates and
lawyers unaffiliated with the case were
interviewed
and we have brittany's own public
statements okay that's that's that's all
the evidence we have to support the
assertion that she is mentally competent
in other words we have nothing we have
no evidence
do we have evidence that bernie spears
should be under the conservatorship
well yeah we do we know that spears had
multiple psychotic meltdowns in public i
mean we saw it happen so that's how we
know it happened
we know that spears was not granted
majority custody or even half custody of
her children
which is a profound statement in and of
itself if you know anything about
the way family court works especially in
california
for a woman to get like a 70 30
arrangement
or she might have lost custody
completely whichever it was she did not
have
even majority custody for that to happen
there's got to be something really wrong
with that woman
we also know that every judge that's
looked at the case and examined her
psychological evaluations
have found that she's mentally unfit
does all of this mean that we in the
peanut gallery can conclusively
determine that britney spears
should be under a conservatorship no we
can't conclusively determine anything
because we don't know her and we don't
know the case
and we don't have access to almost any
of the relevant information
i keep hearing from people oh we grew up
with britney spears we know her
oh you didn't grow up with britney
spears you grew up watching
some music videos of her you did not
grow up with her
you don't know her
but the facts what little facts we have
access to would seem to be leaning
pretty heavily against the free brittany
movement
a movement again spurred on by people
who have made utterly baseless legal and
psychological determinations
a bunch of fans with free britney signs
have just decided
that britney is mentally fit they have
absolutely no
evidence to support this claim none at
all
but let's say the british should be
under conservatorship let's just say
that
let's say that she's mentally
incompetent and a danger to herself
or others would that automatically mean
that nothing abusive is happening to her
under the guise of this legal
arrangement no
she claims for instance that she is
forced to use an iud
and not allowed to have any more
children that would be a horrible
injustice but then again
the key word here is claims she claims
that this is happening
the only evidence we have of this claim
is the claim itself
which she made to a judge recently
here's the full transcript of that
moment i'm going to read this to you
so when you hear this thing about the
iud this is where people are getting it
from this is the only place they're
getting it from
here's the transcript where she mentions
that to the judge
she says team wants me to work
and stay home instead of having longer
vacations they're used to me sort of
doing a weekly routine for them and i'm
over it i don't feel like i owe them
anything at this point
they need to be reminded they actually
work for me i was supposed to be able to
i have a friend that i used to do aaa
meetings with
i did aa for two years i did three
meetings a week i've met a bunch of
women there
and i'm not able to see my friends that
live eight minutes away from me which i
find extremely strange
i feel like they're making me feel like
i live in a rehab program this is my
home
i'd like for my boyfriend to be able to
drive me in his car and i want to meet
with a therapist once a week not twice
and i want him to come to my home
because i actually do
know that i do need a little therapy
laughing
i would like to progressively move
forward and i would want to have a real
deal i want to be able to get married
and have a baby i was told right now on
the conservatorship
i'm not able to get married or have a
baby have it i have an iud inside of
myself right now so i don't get pregnant
i want to take the iud out so i don't so
i could start trying to have another
baby but this so-called team won't let
me go to the doctor to take it out
because they don't want me to have
children any more children so basically
this conservatorship is doing way more
harm than good
so she complains that she wants longer
vacations she wants to go to therapy
once a week instead of two
and she wants her boyfriend to be able
to drive her then at the end as an aside
she just throws in the claim about the
iud
doesn't explain how this even works did
they physically force the iud into her
and what if she goes what if she goes to
the doctor to remove it will the doctor
actually refuse to do it doesn't bother
to explain
she doesn't seem to think that the iud
issue is as important as the fact that
she isn't allowed to take longer
vacations
perhaps the claim is still true but who
knows
well someone knows she knows her dad
knows
the judge might know i don't know
neither do you
in fact you know almost nothing about
any of this
and the same goes for me that seems to
be the overarching theme here
a bunch of people who know almost
nothing and have no evidence of any kind
and have access to none of the relevant
information
have nonetheless made sweeping
determinations and are now calling for
legal decisions to be made
based on their assumptions the whole
thing is absurd
and strange and embarrassing
and we have more important things to be
worried about in this country
and for that reason i must say that the
free britney movement is
today cancelled listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated